offrir un service funéraire à son animal
dans la dignité et le respect c'est
l'objectif de cet établissement installé
à guyancourt le crématorium pour animaux
accompagne chaque jour des familles dans
la perte de leur compagnon il propose un
service de crémation collectives mais
aussi individuelles au même titre que
pour un humain on va préparer l'animal
on va l'installer dans un petit cercueil
et on va procéder à un recrutement c'est
à dire qu'on va présenter l'animal
personnes vont avoir un petit temps qui
leur est propre pour dire au revoir à
leurs compagnons éventuellement laisser
un petit jouet un petit mot si les
personnes ne souhaitent elles peuvent
rester présentes dans la pièce pour
procéder à l'introduction ainsi moment
on va déposer le cercueil dans
l'appareil de crémation quand les
personnes décident d'accompagner leur
animal c'est un choix mûrement réfléchi
ça peut être comparée à un geste d'amour
parmi les 6000 à 7000 animaux traités
ici chaque année plus de la moitié sont
en crémation individuelle
un geste d'amour encore peu popularisé
seulement deux structures de ce type
existent en ile-de-france et les
propriétaires se déplace de tout le
territoire
on a des personnes qui viennent du
centre des personnes qui viennent
d'audace des personnes qui viennent du
nord
nous avions des clients réguliers qui
viennent damien des clients de dijon
malgré qu'ils aient d'autres circuits
dirait classique à leur portée voilà il
préfère vraiment et par habitude
par respect et par amour valérie pour
une crémation individuelle classique
comptait 237 euros pour un chien ou un
chat
créé en 1995 le site a été repris en
2015 par le siav service d'inhumation
des animaux familiers
l'offre est désormais plus personnalisé
et l'établissement a été modernisée une
crémation est actuellement en cours sur
cet appareil on va avoir dans
différentes informations concernant au
bas d'une part la traçabilité donc le
nom de l'animal le numéro de la
crémation
et puis des informations techniques
notamment les températures et bien de la
chambre principale et de la chambre
secondaire là on voit que
lâchant principal est à 800 30 degrés ce
qui est on va dire la température
requise pour
la crémation fabrice a rejoint
l'entreprise en 2014 après avoir
travaillé dans les pompes funèbres
ils sont cinq à accompagner les familles
quatre humains et un chat patch est ici
depuis deux ans son rôle est essentiel
patch est un collègue
voilà qui sert à l'accueil c'est lui qui
va accueillir les personnes qui se
présentent ici il va les accompagner
durant la crémation à leur apporter un
petit moment de réconfort et
éventuellement de rechange et des idées
un compagnon indispensable pour nous un
compagnon pour adoucir la tristesse que
procure la perte de son animal en france
plus d'un foyer sur deux possède un
animal de compagnie